welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're covering servant on appletv
servant has been a pretty crazy show the
entire run has been laced with
head-scratching moments massive twists
and turns and the final episode didn't
pull any punches when it came to some
big reveals chances are you have a hell
of a lot of questions and throughout
this video we'll be breaking down
everything you need to know about the
show and it's ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch the finale yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of servant do you
know okay so servant follows a
Philadelphia couple named Sean and
Dorothea Sean is a highly sought after
chef and Dorothea is a well-known news
reporter and whilst both look like
they've made it on the surface the pair
are actually going through a lot in the
aftermath of losing Ness and Jericho
Dorothy had a complete breakdown and
went into a state of Catania
in order to pull her out this Sean had
to resort to using a reborn doll is part
of a technique known as transitory
object therapy Dorothea believed that
this doll was a real baby and this
seemed to work giving her a new lease on
life they didn't announce the death to
anyone except Dorothy's father and
brother Julian and thus very few people
know the truth
Sean loved his wife so much that he went
along with the entire thing and the two
hired a living care giver named Leon to
come and look after the doll now where
the season started to get complex is
that Liana's well a little bit weird
initially she seemed to believe that
Jericho was real and played into the big
fantasy at work with Dorothy the doll
was creepy as hell but one day Sean
discovered the impossible the doll had
seemingly turned into a real baby and
the season is pretty much centered
around what the character should do with
this where the baby comes from and what
is really going on with Leon it's been
an awesome ride and every week has been
stranger and stranger
I've loved watching the theories over
the season with people throwing their
wild guesses out there and whether it
was the things that played out on-screen
or the internet community itself the
season definitely made you think some
theories have been true some theories
have been false but what kept us coming
back is that the show wasn't quick at
giving any answers however we do finally
know a lot of the ins and outs including
one of the biggest mysteries which is
how did Jericho die initially it was
leaked that he was quote-unquote cooked
and this had people online going wild
believing that Sean may have
accidentally done it during one of his
many chef's moments in the show though
this turned out to be true in some ways
it wasn't as extreme as we all thought
and it was revealed that Dorothy
actually left Jericho in a car on a hot
day and the baby died because of this
Dorothy was pretty much handling all of
the parenting herself while Sean was
away working on a TV show and the big
reveal showcased how exhausting it was
being in an unbalanced parent
relationship where one person works all
the time and the other has to struggle
with the day-to-day
it was kind of heartbreaking seeing this
happen and though the big reveal wasn't
as gory or as shocking as some fans were
initially hoping for it did fit Thome
with the show however that doesn't mean
that everything was straightforward and
the season did tease that something
supernatural was going on Sean began
finding splinters and wood in his body
his ability to taste disappeared and
LeAnn seemed to be at the center of it
in episode 5 titled the cricket we
actually saw a member of the titular
insect family be killed and resurrected
and this sparked up theories that the
living baby which was initially thought
to be Leanne's was actually Jericho
reborn
now there has been a lot of back and
forth on this with some believing that
the doll in fact was brought to life by
LeAnn whilst others believe that it was
just a baby that she smuggled in in a
suitcase
both theories were strangers each other
with it seeming very unlikely that LeAnn
had managed to find a couple who had
just lost their child without them even
really advertising for it
juxtaposing this her ability to
resurrect someone from the dead could
make her seem pretty godly now we did
sort of get answers to this in the
finale or at least enough to interpret
things our own way I'll get into this in
just a bit as we discussed the ending of
the season as for the show itself M
night Shyamalan as always masterfully
laces everything with an atmosphere a
creepiness to it and because of this the
servant is really easy to get addicted
to you though it has a relatively small
cast servant uses each of its actors
expertly and they all bring a lot to the
table
Shawn played by Toby Kebbell is pretty
much the eyes of the audience as they go
on this ride and Dorothy is the other
extreme of that and able to assess
what's really going on and thus you're
basically watching a man in an
impossible situation and trying to save
his marriage from a girl that has the
potential to bring it all crashing down
the aunts uncles also popped up to try
and call a home and he made one hell of
an entrance this is not the kind of guy
that you want to have run for dinner and
he and his wife play a big part in the
finale episode 10 opens with Shawn
preparing the placenta for a meal and
for the final cooking scene of the
season it definitely felt like a fitting
end it's been in the fridge since
Jericho's birth and this liked the
episode it shows that everything is
going to be laid out here he serves it
up to a group and yep I'm never ever
going to one of these ever I can promise
you that it turns out they're throwing a
party for Jericho's baptism I want to
say baptism in the UK we will call it a
christening so yeah let me know if I'm
wrong and Dorothy hasn't held back on
the invitations and many of her friends
and family members come to the house
including a child who snuck in and
brought doll with her the child is taken
home later in the episode by a mother
much in the same way that Leon
eventually is and there's sort of a
setup here of watching someone go back
at the home and taking it all with them
Dorothy catches up to the child and when
talking to her she rebuffs the idea that
a doll isn't real and upon calling it
Pamela she hits a chord with Dorothy who
finally realizes that she's been playing
with a doll too now it's fine that a kid
would think the doll is real as they're
probably just playing make-believe but
for Dorothy it has severe repercussions
as she realizes the reality of the
situation to make matters worse Leanne's
uncle was spotted at the church and
they've snuck into the house throughout
the season we've seen people wandering
around the property and it turns out
that all of these people were connected
to Leon and our auntie and uncle
the Anne catch is a rant with Jericho
and her uncle goes Deshawn for the
blackmail money but he rejects it saying
he wants them back it turns out the ants
auntie and uncle were part of an
extremist religious cult who raised her
after the death of a family the cult
known as the Church of the lesser Saints
believed that the rapture is coming and
have forced LeAnn to live a very
sheltered life similar to Shaun taking
in the mysterious resurrected Jericho
they took her in and raised her as their
own we did learn earlier in the season
that LeAnn had met Dorothy as a child
and she became obsessed with her from
this point onwards Leeanne fled from the
family and they were able to track her
to Dorothy and Shaun because they knew
of a love for the character in the
episode Leanne's uncle says that she
likes to please people she loves and
heard people she doesn't so because of
her feelings for Dorothy she somehow
gave Jericho back to her the way that I
took it is that this love allowed her to
turn this doll into a real child and
provide Dorothy with the thing that she
wanted most in the world juxtaposing
this Leon is capable of hurting people
that she doesn't like and we see this
reflected in Sean who throughout the
season has lost his ability to taste
Sean cares about being a chef above all
else and the death of Jericho can
somewhat be blamed upon his choice of
work over his family so in the end
Leon saw removing his census as a
fitting punishment for the character
Sean breaks down to Leanne's uncle and
confesses that now what he actually
wants more than anything is his son back
and this shows growth in the character
and a change of his priorities he
accepts that Leon brought Jericho back
to life and realizes that if he removes
it from the house then his son is gonna
go with her Sean says he knows his own
child when he holds him and for me this
adds more weight to the theory that
LeAnn was able to return him Leanne's
aunt and may shout at spider-man forces
LeAnn to come home claiming that Leon is
a servant and not Dorothy's Dorothy
recognizes that may but she doesn't
remember exactly where from and tell she
reviews footage of a news report that
she did in which she reported on the
cult during a police standoff they were
seemingly able to escape and this is
likely when Leanne left
the report sends alarm bells ringing and
she rushes to Leanne's room to find her
gone and in Jericho's room that doll is
back in the crib Leanne has returned to
her family and they creepily wait for
her outside they have a massive embrace
in the street with all of them
completely enveloping her for me this
once more showcases that she was of high
importance to them and that her
abilities do indeed exist they disappear
much like their escape from the
authorities and is possible that they've
gone to the rapture the rapture is a
concept within Christianity that states
during a specific event that may or may
not be the end of the world that all
Christians who are alive will rise into
the clouds to meet the Lord in the air
it is possible that the cult members
died in the explosion but Leanne was
able to resurrect them and their
disappearing act could signify this as
for the disappearance of Jericho well
you can pretty much take it one of two
ways
if you don't believe that Leanne has
supernatural abilities and the group
just fled after noticing the police then
is possible that she merely took the
real Jericho with her and left a doll in
its place a group like that would draw
suspicion and clearly they did from the
policeman who even backed up to see what
they were up to you so it is possible
that they noticed the squad car and
either left a hit they'd have to run
faster than Usain Bolt but it isn't
outside the realms of possibility
however if you lean mourn with a
supernatural side of things then Leanne
leaving has also taken Jericho's soul
with her perhaps through religion she
was able to gain he's almost christ-like
abilities and if so I can see the second
season centering around Shawn and
Dorothy trying to get her back Shawn can
now not feel any pain and thus he will
likely be able to push himself to the
limit in order to get the child back
lianna's also clearly taught on a
position in the cult and I don't think
it would take much to persuade her to
return to Shawn and Dorothy as she
clearly found a home that she wanted to
be in and by the end they wanted her to
it was an incredible way to end the show
and I can't wait to see what happens
down the line servant was a great season
that thing stands strong as one of Apple
TV's best entries it was a bit up and
down at times but overall it kept me
coming back to it week after week
wanting to know more this isn't an easy
task
and it's been great going into each
episode not knowing what to expect I
feel like we've got some satisfying
answers for the end of the season as
well as a lot of plot threads that will
make people come back for season two and
yeah
I had a hell of a lot of fun with it
there isn't really anything out there
quite like it and if you were unsure on
the show then I definitely recommend
that you check it out it's unique in
both its subject matter and storytelling
and that's why it gets an 8.5 out of 10
now obviously and love to hear your
thoughts on the season and its finale so
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up make sure you check out our
breakdown of the first two episodes of
The Outsider which are going to be
linked at the end we go over everything
you need to know about the show so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more you can support us by
subscribing to us on patreon and if you
want to come chat to us after the video
you can join our discord server in the
description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey i also just
want to let you know we're currently
giving away a free copy of dr. slick to
one random subscriber and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts and
servant in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February and the cell be
shipped out from the NT over gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]